yeah hello and welcome to our live show
monday evening I look a little bit
blurry there so it's not a very good
that doesn't look good right but while
it's really strange when she looks weird
anyway let's get going I didn't want to
wait any longer to start the show so I
hope you all made it alright to the chat
room and somehow it's just a little bit
loaded wheelchair it changes so that I
actually can read the chat so that's
better now I got to game requests out
and I'm happy to play a couple of five
minute games um yeah who's on a couple
of good guys good players on why is it
so strange i have the same lines out of
their hand every every time okay here we
go wim Alan Helen and then hog hog is
sorta probably something like that so no
stream really I hope it works yeah Ellen
is just playing the claim the fleet
doors with reversal colors
I use dreaming I can see it I can what
why doesn't it work what's happening
here
and then in my life it's coming through
fine yeah okay yeah i lost like half a
minute now okay so um what's going on we
kind of lost track of this game with the
stream issues so I want to do something
here try to put the night on to this
weekend square so what does Ellen up to
so she allows me to place the night day
I let's do it but from here it's not so
easy yeah maybe everything's cool here I
can't play all right yeah ticking on e4
was a little bit on the on the lame side
maybe they are not sure but it is a
fairly solid position here Knight to c4
yeah now I can go a form let's do it
yeah i've i've got a slight class go
against Ellen helland but only slide
five wins two losses so we have sheep
she managed to go before I mean h/o is
hanging kind of but B file is also
hanging kind of let's see I take a true
there's an immediate
b3 idea and after speed up a little bit
em eNOS like a minute with this stream
problems or possible stream problems
okay now she's covered all this so i
probably need to cover be five but yeah
this move it looks a bit weird but i
want to play c5 here we call and if I
get in c4 I'm really happy but she
doesn't want to take I'm sorry Sean
getting some and yeah it's I can't take
I mean taking it's not a totally off but
this is just so nice long term get this
weekend d 3 square
just an extremely comfortable position
how do i how do I continue though the
nights will probably go back to c6 book
a seven that's a where do you go now
move night h2 I am but still yeah 47
still a super solid position form for
white the capture gives me a fantastic
bishop though so I don't think she wants
to take
you
you
nope I did not follow the ICC open ready
I hadn't really slow weekend and didn't
do all that much it was quite enjoyable
and I only noticed that this event was
was going on when it was almost over and
then there was a bit too late at had a
lazy afternoon lazy weekend yeah at the
end that would be a minor piece ending
with four minor pieces just extremely
comfortable for black but not so easy to
get to make something real happen so how
to do that I would probably need to play
some f 5 the knight on c6 is not great
it's tough to say how to do this taking
too long haha I'm taking too long and so
it's difficult to make a grand plan
anyway hmm time morning and this night
is coming to d6 so that's that thing ok
oh I didn't see the check would soon wow
I stumbled into that friggin check here
oh my god hmm that's not good I was the
devil's blonde already and now she's
playing good moves all of a sudden
[Music]
now let's don't stop that great that is
good for me here I think can also take
them or play here c3 is tough to to hold
and she can just take take you for I'm
stupid I was very stupid and completely
unnecessary really could have could have
flagged as much but was much easier I
could have been played and a much easier
way like four days old yeah now I should
have controlled attending a lot better
okay so win at the end yeah we do it by
a new league that was tougher I didn't
see any of that match unfortunately it
was it was not on our free TV and I
couldn't make it work to watch in the
inner in a sports bar or anything like
that I must have been pretty dramatic I
actually managed to watch Dortmund but
they they really didn't get farm cancer
naco so next game I've got the request
out currently I'm doing a decent job
here in the pool keeping above 2400
which is always what I feel is kind of
okay if I manage to keep that
aim sir I am good barczak with that
you're done even offer how many title
players with the name even off how they
acted probably too many to count every
aha interesting I'm willing to play em
yeah thanks for the good feedback on the
ICC video says 33 chance concepts I
think it's a yeah I am feedback has been
very positive so far so thanks for for
mentioning it um g5i you friggin serious
g5 that's funny no red fox that's nice
one saying if i consider myself one of
the best blips players in the world
that's a funny one now maybe one among
the top 1000 or something except it
would probably have probably sounds
right i could have gone to age for
actually in this position maybe okay
it's not so essential yeah borislav you
know giving off that was this the
well-known cheater so I've just put up
the standard venko set up here and black
has blacks position is all over the
place I've got lots of activity here not
quite clear what does G pawn moves for
example what they did
okay i have 95 now as a good move or
just take with 95 looks pretty strong ok
so now i can take here if I like yeah
yeah there are many good lines now ready
for 95 here that looks difficult the
eating's before line in the classical
Kings Indian that's an interesting liner
that was I think recommended by boy boy
boy cough I'm not sure probably
mispronouncing it day on boy cough it
nears a book on the Kings Indian think I
can take here
you know
yeah I'm just winning material here back
you should take c6 they are the the
position at the end is pretty much toast
for like I think Queens the age he more
or less has to play that
at the end of Bishop c5 and Evan a seven
quick Quincy eight if you have to do it
okay the only question is can I do
something better here than just grabbing
you aid probably not okay yeah this is
the simplest continuation
no I did not play the grain cope and I'm
not a huge fan of tournaments with four
double rounds and I also like to yeah I
have a little bit of touristic well you
when i travel to a chess tournament like
see something new and i played the
tournament in france in little and that
fit the bill very well so I'm very happy
with that tournament that played I mean
not with the way I played but the
tournament itself it was a good choice
of tournament then I miss quad Bishop f8
would be seven Bishop f8 doesn't quite
work
I can do this I mean there are many
lines that look very good not sure how
good this is technically speaking really
I scotty's know if I can take a five who
defy the king of seven hmm that wasn't a
good technical flavor lame okay like
still cannot do all that much
oh thats it's pretty stupid i was
thinking that this move isn't even
possible but of course it is that was a
stupid idea but ok it's not a big deal
[Music]
why Mourinho tactic here it's kind of a
shame Abby should be five I can play
King takes us f4 made ya f for checkmate
so I ever win blank resides with murder
checkmate ok so let's go for a new game
the Reykjavik open-air that's an
interesting one really I'd also would
fit the touristic bill I will absolutely
never never ever play a tournament with
the trip around but I mean unless this
is something that's completely
underrated or something ever you can
yeah when you can I mean the bunratty
tournament I think he has a trip around
then that's probably something I would
consider where everybody's based again
drunk and doesn't matter all that much
whole game ok I had this recently
against him and it didn't work out him
all that well and now he takes come on
and I don't think it's particularly
great but he can take Wow
how do you justify this yeah maybe three
against him I actually have considered
this yes really that's possible don't
don't know really I have the check and
engine 97 yeah he's got Knight f3 chick
sometimes anyway oh yeah this is this
I'll play that move anyway so let's do
it and from f/4 let's do it immediately
you have night if form I don't know how
bad that is I mean it looks pretty bad
but it might not be lost or anything
let's see it tough for him to castle
maybe he can get in b5 at some point my
development is also not that fantastic
wow wow whoa Willie so I take and he
takes with the king I can also do this
first
threaten to take here in quincy six
Knight f6 Wow
so I'll take this and then castles
probably he's got before though the
sisters it was just irritating really
[Music]
I Scotty form that that's really a
little bit irritating maybe before is a
move then now you will play you for
anyway everything else looks completely
completely terrible no no the death
death won't work oh it's 92 really 92
I can now can still do that and so
that's pretty remarkable that this is
not completely falling apart and King
aradia he has survived this crap sorry
this is kind of unbelievable but he has
survived this
yeah I don't know how but somehow he has
survived is this weird stuff not good
I just king is seven I don't know what
I'm sorry rookie seven is of course what
I meant
you
you
and believing and losing this game Wow
after this opening that's really really
really hard I was really completely
completely unplayable position for
blanket but he somehow survived it don't
ask me how I'd wine
94 is a bit of an issue maybe this first
it is still somewhat unclear this
position I mean I'm not in good shape
but okay just takes chances
check check check I'm losing this game
oh my god that's really really
unacceptable okay white personalized
after this is opening its really really
tough I'm in here wyd winds probably
with everything I mean I can laughs come
on let's play the legs gate let's play
the next game yoshi yoshi is a really
really dangerous tactical players so
let's see what happens here funky
opening to start with what am I doing
here 94 197 I think you can also go back
yeah yeah I saw that a man Hambleton won
all kinds of games here in the Reykjavik
open but I mean he's not even on a GM
norm performance which shows how tough
this is you beat all those players and
you're not even getting onto 2600
performance ya hear um looks like a
fairly decent position equally sure
would soon
[Music]
yeah I lost against whole game is not
good so what's going on here Bishop g5
business I see the GM known today our
congratulations at school I just saw
that even after some winners he was not
yet on 2600 yes now you see Adam so you
wants to change ok I can I can escape
them
hey I just everyone I guess
and you're just asking if the same is
love is a good way of playing for
Wingard black yeah because why not it's
played by many many top players general
speaking as long as you play a decent
main line everything is some everything
is okay you seem to have questions about
basically every single opening and like
every single one and it's just that the
opening signs are important but not as
important as you probably think so we
are creative a somewhat let's see some F
form and some see why I mean you would
like to play yeah h5 it's not the kind
of thing that makes you very
enthusiastic now you can play many
openings so see phone doesn't do the job
[Music]
mmm to play this in American Cheney I
mean you said such a bad ending I queen
of six hey area he's a tricky player
so now I can actually take and then work
till four says the idea that you
overlooked the swoop defining I think he
did now aged for saying so i can take
with the hook over the Queen okay the
Queen looks good keep more on the bottom
hi morning chicks chicks don't get
anywhere with this try to try to get to
this a 5 pawn g4 working at five is the
plan
white cannot do all that much against
this idea okay in Luke chicks make some
sense so temple okay my ass cannot not
do much 29 seconds this is not snobs at
that nice okay check check that's it
[Music]
play I got him at the antenna law stuff
there was always a little bit worse
there but I'm a little bit worse I think
but any blundered age form it was nice
you can play 1g four against two
thousand one hundred feet them i
downloaded at d4 is really crap I mean
it's really really bad yeah I mean I
don't think I mean no I geforce too bad
i mean if you if you make a world-class
player 1 g for every single game there
the helo goes down back to 2300 maybe or
400 it's really so bad
[Music]
and maybe a bit much I don't know but
it's pretty pretty awful it's always
tough against your cheek minus one now
so I've got a new game requests out
[ __ ] 45 is good I had a couple of games
against started again you're shaking
okay again we know that's going to be an
interesting game then at least we place
the Kings lenient with c6
Wow completely forgot in this area
I have completely forgotten how this is
played I mean like completely I don't
have f3 now
hmm you see the move that's going to be
extremely sharp now how G 596 I just he
just doesn't go for anything like this
but ok so 96 interesting
so 95-96 food
[Music]
I don't know what you're discussing
their really 1g4 sorry so what's going
on I mean I made a video once on that
it's really not it's just bad okay um
how do I play here there's some pressure
against f6 how do i play probably double
here yeah that's funny do I want to take
and then put the bishop on g4
yeah maybe I do
hmm yeah black is the porn up but said
really all that are interesting he plays
it like that but I can take and check in
check check here and wins the exchange a
bit okay I don't need to take any way
I have no time on the clock I don't
think you played as well really I think
I'm finally I'm really fine 93 and so on
the main issue is the time situation
note I don't have much time on the clock
here going forward d2 next
white clay is pretty simple yet I mean I
just have much better pieces should have
gone to deform it's going to be a very
strong deep on now down one minute to
sister the problem
maybe you still can't stand rookie seven
that looks quite terrible but I don't
know what his next moves I want to go
here 9224 no I have to go here five
warriors then bush ocarina three was
better hi 23 was a bit better should
have gone to f3 it would have saved me a
temple
no blood no hooking one that's the only
way to lose this game thank you very
much ah no thank you what a game only I
was completely nostril again so
completely lost anyway okay next game
that would have been the equalizer in
school you know one was a lost one
crucial tempo if I play instead of this
just this the game is just over I just
go here here and he resides I mean the
crate engine is on plus five I am I was
pretty pretty clear that there was a
total win I was the only way to lose the
game give him a full book okay I am
Martin del cumple and got an l a-- cards
here with Bishop c4 and c6 so what does
he do early c4 that's fair that's a
tricky decision often times so how does
he keep the e5 pawn in this position
then I'm curious to learn
how do you keep this pawn rook e1 maybe
and that was the pawn on e5 I think I as
rook e1 Mary it wasn't so terrible as I
thought what he did it was pretty bad
not so bad he has luke t seven then I
should have thought about this
furthermore this is still the
consequence of that that game before I
was playing a little bit too too quickly
him yeah we should all take the same
only only move that makes any sense now
playing this ending
it should be fairly okay my pawn
structure is very sound and the pieces
cannot attack all that much
[Music]
now you should see 54 was two and two
quickly played wants to go to see five
96 probably always threaten me once in a
while
[Music]
to do that I mean f5 at some point
yeah I don't know wasn't quite sure how
to play it I mean but my looks are
pretty actors so I'm I'm pretty sure I'm
okay him but really wasn't sure how to
do it precisely
[Music]
what is he doing if I do this don't
track my roku a short chat my okay that
would be bad but 96 wuxi 598 check is
that really good for him maybe I trap my
look
[Music]
group III should be one I don't tell me
I manage military to tread marks ah
that's bad okay yeah so so this is not
an easy technical task not easy so see
on King yeah probably that doesn't even
do all that much what I'm trying him
just let him try to win this technically
which was we will be very difficult what
it unnecessary game really the opening
position was already completely bad for
white as c4 was completely and to
positional but down yeah then I let him
trap the rope here it's not an easy ely
technical task as mentioned no do I go
f5 I'm i need he wants to bring this
fine morning all the way I guess I've
got King a form
it's not ideal with after playing move
check ok now is doing this quite well
actually
so much easy to win
I made my books are made them look if he
takes a five he has struck this again
what am I playing in this game this is
frigging horrible b6 maybe you have to
go b6 see only move that does not have
my look completely trapped
this isn't easy at all as we see now
like 450 it wasn't really a good game
you know ah ok well that it well i
swindled this ok one more game and we
all stopped to start with this one and
they have one more game against thus far
they are you with the white pieces so we
get King Finian no Petrosian
I think the discussion is the discussion
in the chat is now on beer instead of
the move 1g4 I think this is a huge
improvement so Westphalia now tries to
justify the setup this is interesting
actually that's an interesting way to
play it there is an idea like that in a
related line but the difference is said
here white is not cancelled
if Miller Lite that beer is really worse
than the opening 1g4 and then this must
be really really bad
so what it seemed one idea is to just
play g4y and go for go for the kill but
this is also not bad
let's see Bishop g5 i have on f1 and c6
yes c6 you can sometimes takes you five
play Knight a form probably not here
yeah I think I'll just take and now get
this over now you don't play g4 and over
the board game don't do that please just
for my nerves don't do that ok so here
Bishop takes takes on c5 that looks
pretty deeply terrible let's take can
you hold this somehow takes Knight a
form seen this is already pretty
difficult c5 hangs and he's in all kinds
of pills I also threaten whoopty seven
and 96 these kind of ideas of course my
bishop is completely bad only two but
why a g4 there may be ways to activate
it we'll see ya ok night be 60 on
and looks extremely shaky this position
I come to e3 is also strong 96 route d 8
ok I have to play a game
I wants to take Bishop g5 I shoot that's
a good idea that's a really good idea
huh huh the tent he has defended as well
not sure about this position here maybe
maybe I'm okay but this is a lot what I
wanted to have that was not the plan we
should be for Knight f6 all the Sun
yeah still pretty much have to
jaya he defended this very well before
now is weak and f4 stuff I cannot play
Queen III to Windows porn and his God
rukta for coming which is extremely
problematic here very well played a
virus Vanya it was a very good position
i think at one point for me but he
defended this very well now i have to be
cautious to not lose I hope the two he
just has looped it to hear Jesus why did
I allow that
time morning ah no that is really bad
Queens 26 and nastya I'm just lost
amazing amazing how this is turned
around now maybe that works as well
Mindy 6 just killed had just killed me
this probably also does 24 I don't know
it's just terrible
check check gently yeah and it was
impossible to defend evolution was just
bad that's amazing I really thought that
this position is just completely
completely terrible for black it is not
that terrible it looks it looks horrific
the pro leagues not that bad that it was
a very good news bishop default I mean
it's what he has to do can be one not
something an IT 191 d3 yeah maybe I
should just keep the tensional I can't
be one or something this is of course
good for why damn that can never be a
good position for black and white has
much more spaeth at he's got tons of
weaknesses but can be one anyway I hope
you enjoyed the show at least they were
all interesting games i have found
giving away some points at the end quite
not not necessarily really anyway thanks
for watching guys I'll be back next week
and also I will be I will be on on
saturday for the similar master so I'm
going to post the separate announcement
video for that so um yeah join me also
on saturday if you like thanks for
watching bye bye
you
you